[Music]
i said
he's just resting
in places that man is dead he's so
sleepy
i'm just gonna put your gun down
right here for when you wake
okay yeah
dad
where you going
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
excuse me
do you see this
a quarterly reports on my desk by friday
[Music]
[Music]
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys and
i live
in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed
but then i met her
everybody down on the ground
everybody accept
you
please i have a cold fist there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that put these on okay
fine
oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something
guy there's no easy way to say this this
world it's a video game you're not real
please
[Applause]
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time now
if that's not real i don't know what it
is
i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy next
guy i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity off you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before i really wish you'd
mentioned that yeah
that actually hurt my hand we can save
our world but we have to fight together
[Music]
nope
[Applause]
i can't die
[Music]
[Music]
you